answer me
something question D do I stop for a
minute not when you don't let me finish
I will let me finish I promise I'll let
you give a long answer I'll give you a
long answer if you let me finish this
one sentence I don't support Hamas do
you support Hamas no I don't support
Israel do you support Israel yes and the
Believers will be asked have the
disbelievers been paid for what they
used to do that day is going to
come Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be AAR for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reing the reward
click the link and donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends came across this video of u mean
absolutely annihilating an ex
Congressman who's a Israeli sh I mean
this was one of the most um bizarre ones
I've ever watched my life I mean his
behavior how he grabs the paper out of
his me his hands anger shouting hitting
the table well an absolute weirdo
because he cannot defend Israel's
actions let's get straight into find
this really really amazing Subhan Allah
and shows you the hypocrisy of these
people the kuur the disbelief they have
makes them unjust the biggest unjust is
shik and the biggest Justice is toed
anyone that doesn't have that cannot
apply Justice into the world here is how
it starts let's watch it spoken opponent
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine going as
far as to call it a genocide but when it
comes to Gaza you've criticized people
for calling Gaza a genocide why is that
Joe why is what's happening in Ukraine a
genocide but not what's happening in
Gaza when far more people have been
killed and displaced in Gaza than in
Ukraine I think it goes to motive and
intent I think Putin is trying to kill
and he has been for three years
Ukrainian civilians kidnapping Ukrainian
children his intent is to kill civilians
you and I can arm wrestle I don't think
that's Israel's intent uh at all I think
Israel even though Israeli government
members have said far more genocidal
stuff than Vladimir Putin has completely
there are extreme members of israeli's
govern government not just extreme
members the president the Prime Minister
they're always have been but I but the
president and prime minister of the
country have said stuff that Vladimir
Putin has not said about Ukraine and yet
Joe Walsh if if you said if you said
neither's a genocide then I'd be fine we
move on we'll talk about other things
about Gaza what I find fascinating is
that you're happy to say genocide here
but if you say it there you get mad I
mean that's a fantastic Point made you
know at the end of the day he's that oh
um Putin's intent is to kill everybody
in Ukraine where did he mention that
what do you make a judgment by by his
you can say indiscriminate bombing but
when Israel does the same thing and they
are vocal I've never seen a Russian MP
or defense minister or this minister or
that Minister outright come and call for
saying that the ukrainians are are
subhuman human they are animals they are
this they are that if we had a button
we'll nuke them I don't hear them saying
that but this man says that he um that
Russia wants to indiscriminately kill
everybody but Israel says it does it
we're witness to it we see in hd4k but
he denies it well I don't get mad I I
just think you do I've seen some of your
tweets I just think Putin's intent yeah
is to eliminate the Ukrainian based
based on his actions is is
Israel's words and actions not the same
Israel's actions and words again you can
find some but Israel's I could read you
does be all day if I started reading out
all the genocidal statements from
Israeli Min I can find you a more
history a few days ago of that just a
few days ago the deputy speaker of the
Israeli Parliament and Senior member of
the liquid party netanyahu's party said
that the Palestinian civilians his word
civilians are scum subhuman and the
women and children should be separated
so that men can be killed that is stuff
that mosovich said that is stuff I've
not even heard Putin say I don't hear
Joe W condemning that as genocide well I
I I would condemn that and I will
condemn that statement that's a
genocidal statement that is a genocidal
statement I'm saying medy that is a very
minority view overall in Israel oh my
God in in Israel's government and among
the Israeli people put the Israeli
people to one side we judge them by the
words and
actions hello are you okay are you blind
are you deaf words and actions we've
been seeing what's going on and he goes
That's a minority view but bro that's
the whole view of nearly the entire
Israel Zionist all of them be it your
Layman to your doctor to your salesman
to your defense minister to your
soldiers to the guys right at the top
all of them are in sync People in
podcast saying if I can press a button
and wipe up Gaza I can what are you
talking about is it Israel's intent to
kill to Target and kill Palestinian
civilians 100% yes you believe it has
that's been their intent from one after
OCT they said it Joe they've the guy I
just quoted to you the deputy speaker of
said let's kill all the adult men in
Gaza and I'm put your hands on your ears
no no no I'm telling you that's a
minority of you that's not the majority
okay Benjamin Netanyahu said they are
amalec what is amalec Joe in the Bible
Amal is kill everybody men women
children even the donkeys that's what
Netanyahu said I didn't hear Putin say
that medy again I can find extreme
things that members of Israel's
government has said if is that counts as
intent and that's why they're at the icj
and that's why icj is investigating
that's why some of Israel's leading
Holocaust Scholars have said it's a
genocide and not only that they use
scripture 1 Samuel 15: 2-3 go to amikit
kill men women children babies ox and
Donkey a lot of question people ask a
question what did the donkey do brothers
and sisters they are using scripture
just imagine as as Muslims when these
extremists come and use our religion
falsely where there's no statement in
the Quran had ever tell you to kill inoc
man woman and children or even donkeys
for that matter but they clearly quote
they clearly quote their scripture
imagine that imagine just evidence of
evidence Israel wanted to exterminate
the Palestinian people they could have
done it in three months that's the worst
argument you've ever made in all the
time I've I tell you what Vladimir Putin
could have erased everyone in Ukraine
with a nuke nuke no yes he could oh God
no yes he well with a nuke yeah but with
a nuke then no hold on your argument is
Israel is not genocidal because they
haven't killed everyone in Gaza and they
could I'm saying Vladimir Putin could
kill in Ukraine and he hasn't therefore
according to Joe Walsh's logic Vladimir
Putin is not genocidal a different
situation in this degree Israel is
capable from day one they were capable
oh oh go well only with nukes Israel is
fighting another Sovereign Nation with a
full-on military with the support of the
world Community Ukraine you Russia you
said Israel oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry do you even know what the genocide
of definition of genocide is do you
think that one if I in intend on killing
all Chinese people but I just managed to
kill 5% of them that's not that's still
a genocide you what to this
footage because Gaza over the last 16
months have a look at the screen um has
suffered an apocalyptic level of
Destruction this is a recent drone video
from January 70% of the buildings
destroyed look at that imagery that is
not an anti-terror operation that is not
just targeting Hamas that is look at
look at the imagery that is something
out of I don't I don't even know what to
is that Mad Max movie it's entirety d C
if that's not genocidal I don't know
what is I haven't seen scenes like that
in Ukraine maybe in one town marol but I
haven't seen the entire Gaza Strip Med
by every measurement of urban Warfare
Israel has G please don't give me a
talking point Joe no I'm not I'm looking
at that resp to the footage what to the
footage you don't give a dam about I do
don't say that I do give enge don't give
me some talking about about Urban
Warfare stat I know the stats I can give
you stats I'm asking you to respond to
that footage agreed entire cities and
towns to be rebuilt that's not engaging
with the footage what is your human
reaction to seeing entire town cities
refugee camps wiped out my my reaction
is that really sucks that's horrible
that needs to be rebuilt but I'm not
going to lay the Lion Share of the blame
on Israel the people who WIP that out
the people who chose to drop 2,000 bombs
on civilian Homes apartments buildings
I'm going to lay the Lion Share the
blame on Hamas for starting the war on
October 7th knowing exactly what would
happen how hiding for years behind their
civilians putting their civilians In
Harm's Way I'm not going to blame
strange argument that says they started
a war knowing that would happen so so
hold on so if I start a fight with a
known gangster or murderer and he kills
a bunch of my family respon it's my
fault oh no seriously the law it's a
great you're basically conceding that
Israel was going to respond in a
genocidal way I mean look at how his
body language when he was seeing Gaza
it's like he was shocked like he was
like but is it undefensible he the
defensible and he is still defending and
he's there talking about October the 7th
do you see how when Allah tells us in
the Quran that when we are told that our
limbs will talk our hands will testify
Allah Allah tells us that we ourself are
enough witness it's like his body
language was saying this is horrific
this is a genocide this is crazy these
people should be put to uh put the
capital punishment I mean that's how but
he what his body was reacting and what
his tongue was saying different this is
what you call nef this is unbelievable
this is what you call absolute hypocrisy
335 bullets fired into a car with
children is at a war crime I don't you
know what could be investigate it but
godamn
it this is what Hamas does all the time
hiding behind civilians is war you know
what by the way by the way by the way
you said I I know I see you say this all
the time hiding behind civilians hiding
behind civilians And yet when Israelis
actually use Palestinians as human
Shields you don't say anything last week
emerged have you I checked your Twitter
Joe you can correct me last week it
emerged that 80-year-old man Israeli
press reported was being used as a human
CH they were taking him into houses
putting him in front of them an actual
human shield right they were using a
Palestinian man they've done that many
times do you know they' sent let me
finish the sentence they sent Palestines
into tunnels in Gaza have you condemned
that as have you condemned that as the
use of human Shields I was not aware of
it and if I was aware of it I'd condemn
it's all over the Israeli PR why are you
not acknowledging that this is hamas's
policy and this has been their policy
from day one I a about H is irrelevant
because I don't support Hamas let me
hear you say I don't support Hamas do
you support Hamas no does you support
Hamas do you support Hamas I don't
support Hamas so that D do I support
stop for a minut canish can not when you
don't let me finish I will let me finish
I promise I'll let you give a long
answer I'll give you a long answer if
you let me finish this one sentence I
don't support Hamas do you support Hamas
no I don't support Israel do you support
Israel so that's what we're going to
talk about now stop no no very simple
you're here to support Israel stop but
Hamas talk about something we both with
has been the governing entity in Gaza
for how many years so yes you do need to
talk about Hamas because Hamas did what
they did on October
7 do you condemn yes do you condemn but
you're not condemning Israeli war crimes
that's what I don't understand you're
trying to dodge it with what about is
about Hamas it's a very simple question
I can keep going Let's Play a clip here
let's play a clip for you to watch we
got a clip of a grandmother here's a
grandmother maybe you're not aware of
this this is a by an Israeli sniper who
M I don't know what the hell that was
that's not how do I know it's a sniper
who shot on the Palestinian grandmother
you invite on show me a clip of that you
tell me what it is I'm sorry okay I'm
not familiar with that okay I'd like to
know what that is you know I can go
through multiple examples right you know
that I can start reading multiple
examples the alos family in Gaza whose
apartment building was bomb fantastic
when Israel there's a crime he's not
he's not familiar what is that it could
be anything it could be enlightening it
could have been the it could be anything
but if an Israeli Zionist is killed we
don't brother we will make sure it's
Hamas we will make sure it's Islam we
will make sure we fit in there it's them
but if it's Palestinians we need to know
who was it was it a wind was something
with hard stack you bloody hypocrite
this is from haret last year Israeli
newspaper you're saying you're not aware
of this let me tell you this um an
Israeli soldier uh relays that a senior
Commander asked him to shoot Anon man
with a white flag he said he's got a
white flag he says I don't care shoot
him it's an order another Israeli
soldier told plus 972 there were no
restrictions on ammunition we could just
shoot to relieve our boredom we don't
need to explain you just shoot when
soldiers see someone approaching it's
permissible to shoot them you can shoot
a young girl an old woman this is
testimony from Israeli soldiers Joe that
it's a free fire zone they can shoot and
kill whoever they want that is a policy
that is a war crime and many would argue
that's genocide that is what you're
defending today which is kind of do you
believe answer this question no you I'm
saying I'm saying I condemn that and
hold on I
e to say condemn it why won't you call
it a war crime I'll say what Hamas did
on October 7th was a war crime will you
say what I've described a war crime
Everyone's Watching I'm the what I give
hold on maybe a war crime I don't trust
some International Group who you don't
trust Palestinians who talk about being
I mean you come some their own newspaper
heret is saying that their commanders
were telling them shoot there's a man
with a white flag I don't care the
command is
shoot this is if this not a war what is
it and this man is a bit weird though he
getting really angry
agitated I I find it very weird very
weird very violent starving people in
Gaza are they starving people in Gaza
what would you answer me
something your question are they
starving people staring Cindy McCain is
she anti Israel as well the head of the
world food program Widow of the most
pro- Israel senator in our lifetime she
has said that people are starving to
death in Gaza they're blocking our Aid
trucks she lying is she lying Sydney M
she's blaming Israel is she lying people
in Gaza may be starving is she lying is
what I no no let me damn it Med would
ask then don't ask it four times yes it
the first time and I'm have to repeat it
do me a favor stop let me speak yes
there's starvation in Gaza but gosh darn
it Israel has gone out of their way to
allow Aid in and who stopped the aid I
mean for two three years who's who's got
who's uh robbed the aid trucks and all
the aid coming in Hamas Terr to the US
govern the administration you supported
they didn't present evidence of Hamas
were criminal gangs that Israel actually
supports according to the Israeli press
but let me even when food Aid is not
coming in they blame Hamas like it's
like if a lightning a thunder hit Israel
or something like that they will come
and say it was Hamas like you can't make
this stuff off you can't make and he
goes it gets more crazy he starts
grabbing papers off people people's
hands this the last reaction I'm pro
Israel no I'm pro Israel because the
isra AG with you thousands of Israelis
and I do not sit in front of you and say
that this is all one-sided like
you I'm I'm going to read the quote to
the viewers it is on the Palestinians
that's what you just said I stand by
that so you just lied no hold on I 10
seconds ago you said I didn't say I put
it all on the pales I'm the again don't
put it all on the pales is on the
Palestinians Israel has always wanted
peace that is putting it all on the
Palestinians no hold on no it's not I'll
read it a third time that's all it would
take don't read it a third time let me
answer the freaking question yes the
Palestinian people have to say that and
if they say that medy then the Israeli
people have to accept that I do believe
bull crap if the no you don't if the
palestin I give you evidence the
Palestinian people said tomorrow if they
all rose up they said it in 1993 1988
the Arab the Arab peace initia of 2002
2007 was part of the PLO chapter as of a
few years ago it was it's still part of
hamas's chap this guy is absolutely
unstable that's what I'm going to say
he's unstable and you know what I'm
going to end this with what does Allah
subhana T say in
[Music]
Allah says but on that day the Believers
will be laughing at the disbelievers and
they will sit on on couches looking on
and the Believers will be asked have the
disbelievers been paid for what they
used to do that day is going to come as
you guys commit genocide Massacre call
us the terrorist and laugh and mock at
us on the day of judgment it's a
graduation party for us because of your
oppression to us and we will be on
couches and we will ask and we will
laugh back at you and say have you been
paid back for what you used to do you
evil double standard Hypocrites who has
seen a genocide and cannot even say one
word against it because you've been paid
you scums that's all I have to say
brother sisters till next time